В ефірі «heute journal» з Гайнцом Вольфомта Марієттою Сломкою.
Доброго вечора.
Президент України розповідає про доленосну битву.
Зеленський говорить, що у Сєвєродонецьку
вирішиться доля усього Донбасу.
Росія та Путін настільки сильно прагнуть перемоги,
що посилають військавоювати у населених районах.
Вулиці та будинки під масованим бомбардуванням.
Однак, тільки спостерігаючи, важко говорити
про деталі розгортання війни.
Досі незрозуміло, як Росія уявляє собі перемогу.
Одна справа - підкорити місто,
зовсім інша ж - окупувати цілі регіонита керувати ними.
Крістіан Гоффман розповість
про ситуацію у місті подій.
Тижнями люди на Донбасі ховаютьсяу таких підвалах від ракет та бомб.
З собою у них лише найнеобхідніше для життя.
Тут залишились здебільшоголюди похилого віку та хворі.
Ми майже весь час перебуваємо у підвалі.
Наші домівки поруч, але обстрілитривають днями і ночами.
Люди наважуються вийти на вулицюна короткі миті під час припинення вогню.
І бачать повсюдні кратери та руїни.
Ті, хто там залишились, не хочуть або жне можуть покинути місто.
Де на мене чекають, скажіть? Ніде.
А на кого я залишу свою 85-річну маму?
Вона звідси не виїде.
Це останнє місто у Луганській області,яке Росія ще не захопила.
Важко сказати, що відбувається насправді.
Інформації та знімків з місця подій дуже мало.
Війна триває в населених районах.
Росіяни майже захопили місто,відтискаючи українську армію.
Але згодом обидві сторони відступили.
Міський голова розповідаєпро десятки тисяч мирних жителів,
які застрягли у місті.
Він говорить, що більше немає можливостіевакуювати їх звідти, це надто небезпечно.
Голова Луганської ОДА у інтерв'ю з ZDF
просить Захід продовжувати поставку зброї.
Дайте нам більше далекобійної артилерії,
щоб ми могли знищити російську артилерію.
Тоді наші солдати владнають цю справу.
Доля Донбасу зараз вирішується у Сєвєродонецьку.
Про це говорить президент Україниу своєму відеозверненні.
Він також говорить про плани на майбутнє, а самепро заявку України на вступ до ЄС.
Зокрема, це обговорювалось і з канцлером Шольцом.
Вирішується майбутнє
випускників харківських шкіл.
Вони танцюють на руїнах школи під піснюпро війну, у якій звучать такі слова:
«Вони можуть розстріляти мрію,але вбити волю їм не вдасться».
З нами на зв'язку Олексій Чернишов,
міністр розвиткугромад і територійУкраїни
та представник президента України
з питань перспектив вступу до ЄС.
Доброго вечора.
Ви провели багато переговоріву Берліні та Дюссельдорфі
та сповнені надії щодо перспективи вступу до ЄС,
що Україна стане кандидатом на членствов кінці червня на саміті ЄС.
Але після цього процедура знову може затягнутисьна тривалий термін.
Макрон сказав, що до фактичноговступу України в ЄС,
можливо, минуть десятиліття.
Україна вже протягом кількох років
є членом європейської сім'ї.
У 2014 році ми підписали угоду про асоціацію з ЄС.
Ми багато чого зробили для того,щоб відповідати стандартам
та отримати статус кандидата.
Чекаємо на кінець місяця - 24 червня.
Ми сповнені надії і хотілося брозповісти про наші очікування:
Україні не потрібні поблажки чи
пришвидшена процедура.
Україна здивує ЄС швидкістю своїх дій
та відповідатиме необхідним критеріям,аби стати членом ЄС.
У Європейського Союзу є певні сумніви черезпроблеми України з корупцією
та з олігархічно структурованою економікою.
Очевидно, під час цієї страшної війни такі питаннявідійшли на задній план.
Але коли справа дійде до виконаннязаконів ЄС, викладених на 100 сторінках,
тоді це знову відіграватиме важливу роль, чи не так?
Звичайно, це так.
Ми маємо пам'ятати, що Україна змінюється.
Війна суттєво змінила Україну.
Народ більше не терпітиме корупції,
незалежно від того, хто керуватиме країною.
Беручи до уваги український народта невинних жертв - це дуже важливо.
Українці більше не будуть з цим миритися.
Ба більше, корупція панує і в інших країнах,
йдеться ж про вирішення цієї проблеми
та суттєве зниження її рівня.
Це одна з причин, чому Західні Балкани
не досягли прогресу зі вступом до ЄС.
Дехто крокує цим шляхом вже майже 20 років.
Чи розумієте ви слова німецького канцлера
«Ми маємо бути обережними, щоб Балканине відчули себе обдуреними,
якщо Україні вдасться вступитидо ЄС набагато  ﻿швидше»?
Я думаю, що концепція ЄС полягає в тому,
що двері відчинені для країн,які поділяють європейські цінності
і готові до перебудови,
розвитку та структурних реформ.
З погляду на це ми не хочемостояти на заваді іншим країнам.
Крім того, саме час прийняти Українута надати статус кандидата.
ЄС роздумує над питанням про те,
як можна допомогти Україні відбудуватися.
Тут, у Німеччині, ми бачимо знімки жахливих руїн,
обстрілів та загибелі, пролитоїкрові. Чи можливо відновитися після такого?
Дещо ми вже почали відбудовувати.
Найважливіші інфраструктурні елементи.
Як тільки ми відновимо наземну частину,
то збудуємо помешкання для людей.
До їхнього повернення нам потрібно відновити
центральне опалення та електропостачання,
зруйновані бомбами.
Тож під час війни та надалі ми продовжуватимемотермінові роботи з відбудови.
Після війни планується і стратегічна реконструкція
за планом Маршалла, що проводитиметьсяспільно з ЄС.
Пане Чернишов, дякую Вам за розмову.І Вам дякую.
Інтерв'ю відбулося рано ввечері.
Європейський Союз хоче відігравати
провідну роль у відбудові України.
До питання фінансування треба також
залучити винного, тобто Росію.
Єврокомісія хоче заволодіти
активами російських олігархів.
Яхтами та віллами. Тому буде справедливо,
якщо люди, які збагатилися від розпадуРадянського Союзу,
а згодом
і від мафіозної системи Путіна,
тепер змушені заплатити за збитки,
які вони заподіяли країні.
Але на практиці це не так легко.
Подробиці - у сюжеті Анне Ґеллінек.
Ще одна яхта олігарха,
з якою європейці мало що можуть зробити.
У портах країн ЄС наразі зафіксовано
понад десять«палаців на плаву».
У квітні у місті Пальма-де-Майоркаіспанська поліція обшукала
яхту «Tango», яка належитьросійському мільярдерові
Віктору Вексельбергу.Обшук провели на прохання уряду США,
який уже давно внісім'я багатія в санкційний список.
Американці конфіскують майноросійських олігархів
у всіх куточках світу.
У Європі ситуація інакша:супер'яхти супербагатих росіян
хоча й заарештовують, та поки не конфіскують.
Якщо ми всіх просимозробити внесок у відбудову України,
то залучення Росії, її фінансових ресурсів
й активів російських олігархів -
це, зокрема, й питання справедливості.
Це непросто.
Міністри юстиції країн ЄС вже давно зрозуміли,що Європа втілює принципи
верховенства права, тож конфіскаціяприватної власності має відбуватися
лише за найсуворішими вимогами.
У випадку з приватною власністю можливе
вилучення активів,але для цього необхідно довести
в межах належноорганізованого судового процесу,
що ці особи причетні, наприклад, до воєннихзлочинів або порушення законів та звичаїв війни.
Тож Європейська комісіянамагається піти на хитрість:
обійти санкцій, а саме розглядати переміщення
й приховування майна в будь-якій країні ЄС
як злочин.
На цю думку, за словами Комісара ЄСз питань юстиції, пристають майже всі.
Я поки не можу сказати, що всіодноголосно підтримують цю ідею.
Є ще кілька технічних питань,
пов'язаних з певнимипроцедурами в країнах-членах.
Одне з них - Бундестаг і Європарламент
мають ухвалити такий закон,а це може тривати деякий час.
Тим часом російський бізнесмен-мільярдер
Роман Абрамович перемістив свою яхту «Solaris»
з Барселони до Туреччини - країни,яка не входить до складу ЄС,
і заявив, що оскаржить санкції ЄС
у Європейському суді.
Про те, наскільки узгодженою (чи неузгодженою)є позиція Заходу щодо Росії,
згодом обговорюватимеМайбріт Іллнер зі своїми гостями
одразу після випуску «heute journal».
Також ви можете знайти низкурепортажів і додаткової інформації
про цю війну онлайн, на сайті zdf.heute.de.
Більше новин розповість Гайнц.
Проблему війни Росії проти України сьогодні порушив
в Берліні канцлер Німеччини Шольц
на цифровій конференції «re:publica».
Шольц звинуватив Росію в імперіалізмій наголосив, що така політика
ніколи не знайде схвалення.
Звідси - санкції проти Росії й підтримка України,
як економічна, фінансовагуманітарна, так і військова.
Після того, як у Берліні автомобіль в'їхав у натовп,
спричинивши смерть жінкий травмування понад 30 осіб,
водія авто планують госпіталізуватив психіатричне відділення.
За даними прокуратури, є підстави вважати,
що він хворий на параноїдну шизофренію.
Повідомляють, що 29-річний чоловік уженеодноразово потрапляв у поле зору поліції.
Водночас наразі невідомо, чи мали його вчинкиполітичне чи екстремістське підґрунтя.
Увечері керівна бургомістерка Берліна Ґіффай
і прем'єр-міністр землі Гессен Райн
поклали квіти на спомин жертв і постраждалих.
Серед них були також школярі з Гессена.
Усупереч сподіванням,рівень інфляції не зменшується,
а навпаки - зростає.
Після понад десятирічної надзвичайно м'якої
монетарної політикиЄвропейський центральний банк
має намір підвищити процентні ставки.
Запитаймо Штефані Берретт: які плани має ЄЦБ?
Сьогодні ЄЦБ сигналізував про історичне рішення:
тепер заборгуватися знову коштуватиме дорого.
Це стосуватиметься як споживачіві компаній, так і держав.
На липневому засіданні ЄЦБ
планує підвищити ключові процентні ставки:
Перед цим банк припинить свою програмувикупу державних облігацій,
щоб грошова маса надалі не збільшувалася.
За цією програмою впродовж багатьох років
отримувати дешеві кредитимогли насамперед країни ЄС.
Тепер ЄЦБ зупиняє таку монетарну політику,
тож країни ЄС з великими боргамимають бути обачними:
з огляду на рівень боргу,який значно зріс на тлі криз,
набирати додаткові державні боргив разі підвищення процентних ставок
буде небезпечно.
Якщо досі ЄЦБ доводилося звинувачувати
у применшенні значення питання інфляції,то сьогодні в Амстердамі
президентка ЄЦБ Крістін Лаґардзробила нові чіткі заяви.
Мовляв, інфляція - це величезний викликдля всіх нас,
останнім часом вона поширилася і посилилася.
Тому ЄЦБ змінює прогнозищодо інфляції на цей рік
і тепер чекає інфляцію на рівні 6,8%.
Лише драйвери інфляції - енергіяй харчові продукти -
це те, за що ми, споживачі,перейматимемося найдовше.
Ключове слово тут - споживачі.Тож чи вже можна прогнозувати наслідки
цього рішення для наших споживачів?
Зміна процентних ставок уже прийшлана ринок нерухомості.
Хто планує придбати будинок чи квартиру,
той вже кілька місяців томупомітив зростання процентних ставок.
З грудня процентні ставкиза іпотечними кредитами зросли втричі,
хоча вони досі залишаються історично низькими.
Водночас ситуація щодо процентних ставокза вкладами залишається невизначеною,
тож заощадникам ще треба набратися терпіння.
Усе ж таки від'ємні процентні ставкинезабаром зникнуть.
З огляду на підвищення процентної ставки
більшість банків уже припинилинараховувати від'ємні проценти
за ощадними вкладами своїх клієнтів.
Цінні папери з фіксованою процентною ставкою,зокрема державні облігації,
знову зможуть зацікавити інвесторів, тоді як акціївтрачатимуть привабливість через вищі ризики.
Сьогодні це можна прослідкуватина німецькому біржовому індикаторі:
одразу після рішення ЄЦБфондовий індекс DAX стрімко впав
і на момент закриття бірж знизився до -1,7%.
На фінансовому ринку економістисприйняли рішення ЄЦБ
досить обережно, мовляв,уже запізно намагатися гальмувати інфляцію,
і було б занадто самовпевнено вважати,що цей крок спричинить справжню
зміну тенденцій у монетарній політиці.
З нами була Штефані Берретт, дуже вдячні.
На цю тему в нашому випуску «heute journal:update»
свою думку висловить економістка.
Сьогодні у великих морських портах Німеччини
страйкували тисячі портових працівників,
значно затримавши цим, як повідомляєпрофспілка, реєстрацію контейнеровозів.
Превентивні страйки охопили портив Гамбурзі, Емдені,
Бремені, Бремергафені й Вільгельмсгафені.
У межах тарифного конфліктуспілка «ver.di» вимагає підвищити заробітну плату
й компенсувати вплив інфляції
для приблизно 12 000 співробітників.
Завтра має розпочатисянаступний раунд переговорів.
Напад Путіна на Україну вкотре продемонстрував
світу цинічну думку:
той, хто має ядерну зброю, можедозволити собі більше, ніж інші,
а на того, хто її не має, легше напасти.
Гарантії безпеки, які колись отримала Україна
в обмін на відмову в 1990-х від ядерної зброї
радянських часів, зрештою нічого не варті.
Можливо, цей наочний приклад лише посилив
ядерні амбіції деяких держав,зокрема Північної Кореї чи Ірану.
Конфлікт з Іраном дедалі загострюється.
Тегеран заявив про наміриприскорити збагачення урану
і демонтував камери спостереження
Міжнародного агентства з атомної енергії.
Більше розповість Камран Сафіарян.
На іранському державному телебаченні
речник офіційно оголошує:
Іран демонтує камери спостереженняна своїх ядерних об'єктах.
Окрім цього, Тегеран планує запустити ще швидші
центрифуги для збагачення урану.
Директор МАГАТЕ у Відні попереджає,
що Іран скоро накопичить
достатньо матеріалу для виготовлення бомби.
В Ірані було демонтовано 27 камер.
Ми перебуваємо в дуже напруженій ситуації.
Перемовини для відновлення ядерної угоди
зайшли в глухий кут.
Ґроссі додав, що якщо камерине встановлять знову,
це може бути «смертельним ударом».
Члени МАГАТЕ у Відні скаржаться,
що Іран не хоче співпрацювати,
а нещодавно на трьох об'єктах
виявили сліди збагаченого урану.
Іран вже давно перевищив межіядерної угоди, з якої у 2018 вийшли США.
Тегеран збагачує уран вище узгодженого ліміту
в 3,67%.
Якщо ж це число збільшиться до 60%, то наблизитьсядо 90%, що дозволить створювати ядерну зброю.
Окрім того, згідно з даними МАГАТЕ, Тегеран збагатив
у 18 разів більше урану, ніж йому дозволено.
Кількість центрифуг також перевищує
узгоджений ліміт.
Ізраїль звинувачує Іран у спробі приховати дійсність.
В моїх руках докази їхньої брехні.
Іран викрав секретні документи МАГАТЕ,
аби з'ясувати, що саме шукає Агенція в Ірані.
Відповідно, вони вигадують історії,
щоб знищити докази наявності у них ядерного матеріалу.
Ісламська держава перебуває у скрутному становищі.
Країні терміново потрібна угода щодо атомної енергії,
аби позбутися санкцій Заходу.
Декілька днів люди протестують проти різкого підвищення цін,
яке обтяжує економіку.
Молодь висловлюється досить прямо:
ми знесилені, ми дійсно втратили надії
на майбутнє та життя в цій країні.
Це катастрофа.
Ми всі більше не можемо вибратися з цього становища,
що б ми не робили або де б ми не працювали.
За словами іранських експертів, війна в Україні
дає нові можливості ізольованому та санкціонованому Ірану.
Оскільки Іран є одним із лідерів великої кількості
нафтових та газових родовищ у всьому світі.
Через ситуацію з Росією Захід міг би розраховувати
на іранський газ та нафту.
Тому Захід має бути зацікавлений в тому,
аби врегулювати непорозуміння щодо ядерної енергіїта санкцій.
Так Іран міг би вийтина світовий енергетичний ринок
і звільнити Європу від економічного тиску.
Однак між Іраном та Заходом і досі панує супротив.
А тепер Гайнц розповість про інші новини.
Міністр транспорту та цифрової інфраструктури НімеччиниВіссінґ виступив проти заборони продажу
нових транспортних засобівз двигунами внутрішнього згоряння з 2035 року,
за яку вчора проголосував парламент ЄС.
Віссінґ виступає за те, аби дозволити використання
двигунів внутрішнього згоряння після зазначеного терміну,
якщо вони працюватимуть лише на синтетичному пальному
та будуть кліматично нейтральними.
Результат голосування в парламенті ЄС
ще потрібно обговорити з країнами-членами ЄС.
На тлі збільшення випадківінфікування мавпячою віспою
постійна комісія з питаньвакцинації проводить
щеплення певних груп населення,
зокрема, дорослих, які мали тісний контакт зінфікованою людиною,
або тих, хто перебуває в групі ризику зараження.
Комітет з вакцинації оголосив сьогодні відповідний проєктрішення.
У Німеччині, згідно з даними Інституту Роберта Коха,
на сьогодні зареєстровано 131 випадок.
На Півдні Іспанії лісова пожежа загрожує частинікурортного регіону
Коста-дель-Соль.
Понад 2000 осіб евакуювали в безпечне місце.
У важкодоступних місцях, приблизно за 100 км на західвід Малаги
полум'я не вщухає ще від учора.
Працюють сотні рятувальників, троє пожежниківотримали поранення.
Спека, посуха і сильні вітриускладнюють гасіння пожежі.
Причини її виникнення досі невідомі.
Картина «Die Fuge», яку написав Нео Раух у 2007 роціспеціально для своєї виставки
в Музеї мистецтва Метрополітену в Нью-Йорку.
«Мистецтво фуги», так би мовити,є типовим для Нео Рауха.
Велике, колосальне, реалістичне і водночас
сюрреалістичне і мрійливе чи кошмарнез власною кольоровою гамою.
Але є інший Нео Раух -
художник таких монументальних робіт.
Нині можна побачити повну колекцію його графіки та гравюр
в окремому місці.
Детальніше - Андреас Вайзе та Хаґен Мікулас.
Він один із найуспішніших німецьких художників сучасності,
голова Нової школи Лейпцига - Нео Раух.
Однак це не Лейпциг, а це не картини.
Його графічні роботи, гравюри, можна побачити тут,
в Ашерслебені - місці, де він провів своє дитинствота молодість,
місці, яке донині впливає на нього та його роботи.
Мене не цікавить життя в місті,
принаймні не як художника, оскільки там я не можу знайтижодного сюжету,
який хотів би зобразити на своєму полотні.
А саме в цьому шарм маленького міста.
Вже 10 років Нео Раух знову і знову проводить виставкусвоїх робіт в Ашерслебені.
Цього року відбулась найбільша презентація
його графічних робіт - 150 картин, які він створювавпонад 30 років.
Ця картина - його остання робота.
Уже декілька місяців образ муляра переслідує мене.
Товариш муляр.
Він одягнений у біле, тримає свій інструмент
і, очевидно, будує повітряні замки.
Я також будую повітряні замки й маю стежити за тим,
як утримати їх в рівновазі.
І все це на нестійкому підґрунті.
Водночас, мені здається,
що це метафора нашого існування.
Просто зараз.
Ашерслебен - найстаріше містоСаксонії-Ангальт у передгір'ї Гарца.
Воно розквітло з часів виставки садівництва
та міжнародної будівельної виставки у 2010 р.
А Фонд графіки Нео Рауха,
якому належить більшість графічних робіт,
привертає міжнародну увагу.
Чудово, що найвідоміший син міста
знайшов шлях до своєї маленької батьківщини,
завдяки Фонду графіки Нео Рауха.
Ашерслебер пишається цим.
Щороку в травні колекція продовжує поповнюватись.
Я постійно відчуваю прагненняприсвятити себе графіці.
Це двигун, який змушує мене рухатися та сигналізує,
що наближається травень, і потрібно зробити одну чи дві,
а краще три графічні роботи.
Це особливий зв'язок лейпцизького художника Нео Рауха
з Ашерслебеном.
Це були всі новини,а зараз на вас чекає Майбріт Іллнер
із гостями програми.
А о 0:45 запрошуємо до перегляду «heute journal:update»
з Ґундулою Ґаузе.
Зустрінемось завтра.До побачення.
Доброго вечора.Одного разу вже пройшов тропічний шторм з іменем «Алекс»,
тож наразі біля Ісландії та Ірландії
вирує «Ексалекс».
Разом із циклоном «Ченком» вони гарантують,
що на вихідних погода буде літньою,
температура на Півдні Німеччини досягне позначки 30°С.
Сьогодні вночі ще трохи дощитиме в передгір'ї Альп,
а також у Баварському лісі, в інших регіонах буденевелика хмарність або ж ясне небо,
подекуди дещо утворюватиметься туман.
У Лужиці температура впаде до позначки 13°С,
та 6°С в західному високогір'ї.
На Північному морі та в передгір'ї Альп
завтра температура підніметься до 19°С.
В інших регіонах стовпчик показуватиме від 20 до 26°С.
В п'ятницю погода буде чудовою,
світитиме сонце.
Вранці може дощити у Нижній Баварії,
вдень на крайньому Заході також очікуються незначні опади.
Найближчими днями погода буде літньою,
тільки на Півночі пройдуть зливи,
температура становитиме від 19 до 30°С.
На новому тижні погода буде мінливою
і не такою теплою.
Як можна побачити на графіку температур для Ульма,
вона сягатиме від 20 до 25°С.
Часто світитиме сонце
із можливими зливами та грозами.
З цими прекрасними прогнозами на вихідні